تحبط الاوكران والامريكان لكن
خيبة امل امريكا الكبيرة جاءت من
الفلسطينية في الجزائر بدعوة من
الرئيس عبدالمجيد تبون. روسيا
لترسيم الحدود في فرنسا ازمة
الوقود تفجر غضب الفرنسيين مع
الصيني لتايوان مع العداء
المتزايد بين بكين وتايبيه.
طوابير طويلة امام المحطات. جولة
حوار تنطلق بين الفصائل
السوريين وتمنعهم من السكن في
الف ومئة وتسعة وستين حيا. مصادر
رئيسة تايوان وفي احتفالها
بعيدهم الوطني وتقول شرط عودة مع
التركية تفرض قرارات جديدة تضيق
بها الخناق على اللاجئين
بالقوة غير مقبول البتة. ومبدأ
صين واحدة غير قابل للتفاوض.
لتقولها بكين لتايبيه. لن تنفعكم
امريكا ايها التايوانيون. لتأتي
ولكم الاختيار يا هؤلاء. الصين
الواحدة. الصين الواحدة. الصين
جونغ انتهاء بلاده من تدريبات
نووية تكتيكية فما هو التالي يا
في الحصول على الدعم وتعزيز
استراتيجية السعي الى الاستقلال
كذلك يا متابعي قناة شاهد لتعرف?
الاحداث والتطورات. الحكومة
لبنانية مطلعة. لبنان يتجه الى
الموافقة على العرض الامريكي
للبلاد. ومن جانب اخر ومع تصاعد
التوترات بين الكوريتين اعلن كيم
الصين ان تقبل استقلالنا. وبكين
ترد الاعتماد على القوى الخارجية
الواحدة. انها حرب الاندومي. لقد
مللنا من كثرة التهديدات. اليس
اليوم يؤمن الغذاء في بلاده
بزراعة الخضار في قاعدة كان
كيم. الصين تطالب بالحرب. ليست
المرة الاولى ولن تكون الاخيرة
يستخدمها لاطلاق الصواريخ لكن هل
هو تأمين للغذاء ام غطاء
الخليج لشراء اسلحتهم من روسيا
والصين؟ هناك ستكون القاضية يا
ابناء العم مزرعة كيم النووية.
نعم ولنتوقع منه اي شيء ها هو
نعم. اصحاب العيون يفرضون قوتهم
ويعيدون صوتهم مجددا. لا نقبل
يعيد تقييم علاقة بلاده
بالسعودية بعد قرار اوبك بلس
وآآنيك بعيد ميلاد سعيد ان شاء
الله بالعز وطولة العمر. شكرا.
للصواريخ يا كيم يرد كيم انه من
الضروري بناء مزيد من المزارع
الاسلحة للخليج كما يقولها
الامريكان. لكن ماذا لو اتجه
سياسة الانتقام ضد الخليجيين
الانتقام الذي سيكون بمنع بيع
يجعل بوتين هدفا مشروعا. بينما
الرد الروسي جاء حاسما وسريعا.
المخابرات الامريكية قال ان
الجيش الامريكي اقترح على ادارة
السنوات المقبلة وكل ذلك سيتضاعف
بحسب قول الرئيس الاماراتي لينطق
الدفيئة الضخمة مثل مزرعة ريومبو
الدفيئة في كل اقليم في من اجل
بحسب قناة سي ان ان مع تلويح
المشرعين الامريكيين بانتهاج
يراودني هنا سؤال. هل يجيد بوتين
اللغة العربية ام هي الفرحة ما
بوتين كلمة شكرا بالعربية.
الرئيس انا سعيد جدا آآ بلقياك.
الولايات المتحدة. الخليج يقترب
من بوتين. لا شيء يظل كما هو في
الفأس ان يقع على الرأس. فهل
سيقع وبعد ان ظلت الدول العربية
نوفمبر المقبل. روسيا ابدت
تجاوبها مع المقترح. هنا وزير
موسكو تنفذ هجمات سيبرانية على
مطارات امريكية في جميع انحاء
جعلته ينطقها بالاجتهاد هنا تبدأ
واشنطن باعادة حساباتها بايدن
الناشيونال انترست الامريكية ان
الناتو لن يكون قادرا على مد
بين البلدين تضاعف من مليارين
وخمسمائة مليون دولار الى خمسة
مليارات دولار لافتا الى وجود
اربعة الاف شركة روسية في
ابرز حلفاء واشنطن في المنطقة
يتغير الوضع اليوم. وبعد قرار
اوكرانيا بالاسلحة في الشتاء.
وبعد كل هذه المستجدات اعرب
الاوكرانية وسينهي الازمة
العالمية? لتنتقل الحرب من
مع موسكو. بن زايد يلتقي بوتين
ويشير الى ان التبادل التجاري
منظمة اوبك بلس الاخير يتجه ابن
زايد وابن سلمان لبدء مهمة صعبة
وهنا ديمتري بيسكوف المتحدث باسم
الرئاسة الروسية يؤكد انه يتم
الروسي سيرجي لافروف يؤكد ان
بلاده لا تمانع عقد هذا اللقاء
هذه الحياة. قاعدة لم تأخذها
امريكا بعين الاعتبار حتى كاد
فهل سيكون هذا اللقاء المرتقب هو
الذي سيطفئ لهيب الحرب
فلاديمير بوتين على هامش قمة
العشرين المقررة في اندونيسيا في
في مواجهة الطوفان الروسي.
المسؤولون الامريكيون قلقون بعد
كسب الحرب سريعا لتطالب امريكا
وتكرر مناشدتها للمواطنين
خوفهم الاكبر ظلوا الدخول في حرب
نووية. بينما كشفت صحيفة
ندعو روسيا الى اخراج قواتها
فورا من اوكرانيا ووقف عدوانها.
السياسة الى العالم الافتراضي
هناك. وبحسب وسائل اعلام امريكية
اذ انها مستعدة للنظر في اي
مقترح بشأن لقاء بين الرئيسين.
انفاق واشنطن اكثر من سبعة عشر
مليار دولار تجاه اوكرانيا لكن
ضمان امن الرئيس الروسي بالشكل
المناسب ويتم اخذ جميع التهديدات
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عدم
استبعاد لقاء نظيره الروسي
لكن المستشار السابق للامن
القومي الامريكي لم يكن هادئا
بايدن ارغام على قبول السلام مع
روسيا مقترح قد يجعل كييف وحيدة
توفير الخضروات للشعب بكثرة في
ظل الظروف المناخية الطبيعية
بعين الاعتبار. فانت ايها
السيناتور الامريكي وهنا ضابط في
مؤكدا ان الولايات المتحدة
ستواصل دعمها وستجعل روسيا تدفع
الدفاع الروسية حققنا كل اهداف
الضربات الاخيرة على اوكرانيا.
قدر بايدن ويطلق تصريحا جريئا.
استخدام موسكو للاسلحة النووية
باي تدخل اجنبي في اراضينا. لكن
لا يستبعد احد فرضية الغزو
الثمن وذلك بسبب عدوانها ضد
اوكرانيا بينما تقول وزارة
ندين الهجمات الروسية على
اوكرانيا التي تظهر وحشية موسكو.
لن نتراجع عن دعم كييف. ليخرج
نائب وزير الخارجية الروسي ويهدئ
الامريكيين بسرعة مغادرة
اوكرانيا كون روسيا ستستخدم
اوكرانيا بينما تصدر تصريحاتهم
بعدم التراجع قيد انملة اي نحن
قال انه تورط الولايات المتحدة
واوروبا في الصراع بشأن
مناسبة بما في ذلك الاجراءات ذات
الطبيعة غير المتكافئة بسبب ما
الاوكراني يرد ان بلاده لا يمكن
ترهيبها، وامريكا ستعقد اجتماعا
اسلحة عنيفة في هجمتها القادمة.
وهنا بايدن يعاود الظهور ويقول
على مستوى كثافة الضربات
الصاروخية التي تمت مؤخرا من اجل
اوكرانيا. وهنا ستقرع اجراس
الحرب العالمية. فعلى المسؤولين
مجددا لتعود اصوات صافرات
الانذار في شوارع اوكرانيا الكل
اوكرانيا. فمن يحذر في الكرملين
طالب الكثيرون موسكو ان تحافظ
صالح روسيا. لكنه حذر ان روسيا
ستضطر الى اتخاذ اجراءات مضادة
في الناتو وواشنطن بعواقب ذلك.
عن اي تهديد نتحدث لكن الرئيس
الخليج وروسيا حلف جديد يقض
مضاجع الامريكان وواشنطن تبدأ
للهجوم الوحشي مجددا. وباكثر من
ثمان صاروخا يعيد بوتين الهجوم
العنيف. صمت قليلا حتى شعر
بتمادي خصومه. غضب وازداد غضبه
ديمتري ميدفيديف تزويد نظام كييه
بصواريخ سيؤجج الصراع في
طارئا فيما يسمى بمجموعة السبع
لمناقشة القصف الروسي الاخير على
حتى افلت الامر من يده. نعم.
فرده لم يعد سوى ردة فعل
الامارات واكد ان بلاده ستعمل
على مضاعفة التعاون مع روسيا
الوضع قليلا. الصدام المباشر مع
الولايات المتحدة والناتو ليس في
لهجماتهم حتى جاءت عملية جسر
القرم وطفح به الكيل واعد بوتين
الصين وبكين تعلن الا تراجع عن
مبدأها فهل حان وقت الغزو?
يجري لكي ينجو يا لهذا الغضب.
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
اولى خطوات الانتقام والجزائر
توحد الشعب الفلسطيني. رد موسكو
وخطوة امريكية في اوكرانيا قد
تؤدي لحرب عالمية. جيش بوتين
اوكرانيا من جديد. وواشنطن تتوعد
بتخطي الخطوط الحمراء. ولهذا
زالنسكي على الاستسلام فهل تدير
واشنطن ظهرها لكييف والمجنون
يعمل على زراعة الصواريخ فكيف
ذلك? تايوان تتراجع عن تهديد
الخفي يواصل هجماته على الولايات
المتحدة. اقتراح امريكي بارغام
السبب بايدن يطلب لقاء بوتين
بشكل عاجل. وموسكو لا تمانع
بايدن يهدد. روسيا ستدفع الثمن
غاليا. والضربات الروسية تمطر
الان القائد الجديد الذي هو
اشتهر تاريخيا في حرب الشيشان
وسوريا ويميل الى سياسة الارض
المحروقة واؤكد يميل الى استخدام
مصطلح او مفهوم الارض المحروقة.
حلفائهم الخليجيين. فكيف ستجدد
واشنطن علاقتها